blue et manfred c'est un spectacle qu'on
peut voir en ce moment la choucrouterie
alexandre lutz et vous enseigner la mise
en scène est cosigné l'écriture du
spectacle vous êtes sûr vous avez un
site internet avec votre nouvelle
compagnie le coût de la pomme n'ont pas
encore les moyens a les moyens c'est
quand même un moyen de communication
ça m'étonne que beaucoup de ces
peut-être pas encore le moment mais que
les troupes n'est pas encore eu envie de
faire leur leur promotion par le biais
d'internet
donc moi je ne les ai pas moins cher
qu'une page dans les dna faut le dire
oui m'enfin esclave commencé avec les dn
loup et manfred c'est une pièce qu'on
peut voir dans la petite salle de la
choucrouterie on va en voir tout court
extrait je crois que ça nous permettra
de prendre la mesure de ce de ce qu'il
dit
look et manfred quand je repense à cette
période s'était pas marrant manfred
n'avait plus de boulot le saltimbanque
étaient au chômage technique
pourtant j'aime et du mien j'envisageais
déjà de faire un stage de réinsertion
dont sur fuck loric ou majoré dans une
fanfare
mais même quand tendance l'accent ça se
voit bref je tournais en rond dans
l'appartement me pas ton avec
shakespeare
d'ailleurs ça n'a jamais été monté non
leur petit changement d'abord touché le
milieu culturel
puis tout le reste a suivi les
journalistes comme moi et nathalie louis
marc
enfin des gens qui avaient de petits
commerces des boîtes de com des
restaurants trois fois rien il y avait
un agent de la commission d'hygiène par
salle de bains et une lettre de
dénonciation par byd et les remises
malabat on a compris
on est dans une fiction d'un futur
relativement proche est une fiction qui
n'est pas franchement drôle non même si
le spectacle
les deux temps en temps parce que c'est
un spectacle qui raconte un peu la vie
et que la vie parfois des drôles les
plus émouvantes
c'est c'est enfin oui c'est dans une
dizaine d'années quelque chose comme ça
ça se passe en 2006 un petit peu avant
un petit peu après enfin la chronologie
est très éclaté et c'est l'histoire d'un
couple à strasbourg pendant que la
municipalité est prise par la ligue
nationale qui est un parti d'extrême
droite donc voilà toute ressemblance et
il m'a dit c'est une cc pour conjurer le
sort que vous avez eu envie d'écrire
cette pièce c'est parce que ça me ça me
fait très peur quoi surtout et je crois
que c'est possible très possible à vous
lectrices cette compagnie avec vos amis
allaient ses premiers spectacles de
compagnies c'est le premier spectacle de
la compagnie bout de la pomme qui a
pendant toute l'année a fait des
lectures quoi surtout pour pas qu'elle
fasse rien qu'elle bat parce que c'est
toujours difficile de faire un premier
tri classe et ça a plutôt que d'attendre
quand vous ouvre les portes
il faut parfois les enfants c'est un peu
voilà donc vous avez fait des lectures
de différents textes dans un dans un
café à strasbourg et là c'est le premier
et là c'est la première création que
vous que vous créez entièrement on va
voir tout de suite à un deuxième extrait
parce que c'est à la fois l'histoire de
ce couple et à travers ce couple bas
c'est un peu l'histoire de l'imaginaire
fictives
dans tous les cas on l'espère de
strasbourg d'ici quelques années
oui chez nous ici à castres où tout va
bien bien très bien
la première s'est bien passé c'est
toujours de la virvée plein tous les
soirs bien mais critique sens très bien
c'est bien je vois mes amis et parents
la femme de mon frère est toujours et
encore 1,5 j'espère que tu vas bien
strasbourg
tiens je t'aime des biens je crois que
kassoum a vraiment beaucoup manqué
j'adore ça c'est très bien à très
bientôt
je t'embrasse louis manfred c'était
toute cette semaine à la choucrouterie
dernier représentation pour l'instant ce
soir à 20h30
alexandre et puis peut-être qu'on aura
l'occasion de revoir ce spectacle ici ou
là ouais on va peut-être essayer de
l'emmener ailleurs ou enfin de le
reprendre plus tard parce qu'on a eu
très peu de temps pour le pour le faire
donc y revenir et repensé et puis le
d'accord dans tous les cas on vous
attend
[Musique]